[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen oder keine
ahnung welche tageszeit gerade ist
erwartet uns allerdings auf jeden fall
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
hält und meine lieben freunde ihr seht
schon ich befinde mich hier in meiner
skelett dass das problem da sind viel zu
viele skelette drin und wir müssen jetzt
erst mal töten von daher nehme ich mir
ganz schnell hier kurzreisen schwerte
und schlage jetzt einmal
[Musik]
da kann wirklich da kam ordentlich was
raus wir ziehen uns nun allerdings auch
schon direkt wieder aus unserer skelett
falle beziehungsweise monster falle hier
vorne wir doch schon dass es anscheinend
ja noch gar nicht die ganze hier zu ende
durchsuchten das würde ich sagen machen
wir allerdings von anders denn die sonne
geht schon wieder runter und wir haben
für heute wieder extrem viel auf unser
tool ist ich habe nämlich fünf große
sachen da drauf und zwar wie die erste
sache schon fertig gekriegt das war
nämlich skelette töten ich will mal ganz
schnell hier vorne rüber so dass ich den
rest darüber laufen kann
das skelett haben wir bereits getötet
dementsprechend habe ich dadurch auch
eine menge erfahrung eine menge
erfahrungspunkte sammeln können
mittlerweile habe ich sogar schon 38
level und das sollte auf jeden fall für
das ausreichen was als nächstes auf der
liste steht denn ich kann nun endlich
meine glück drei diamant spitzhacke
vernünftig reparieren
von daher gehe ich ganz schnell schlafen
und nun sprinten wir 40 mein gott ich
erschrecke mich da immer so in ordnung
bringen will dir vielleicht noch jemand
um die entwicklung hier
[Musik]
ich kann nichts dafür
das soll auch der war das mein gott ich
dachte vorn hat sich ja auch noch
irgendwie bewegt das schwein ist immer
noch verkehrt herum wir haben allerdings
nun erst mal wieder ein weiteres ziel
auf unser tool ist das hab ich euch ja
gerade schon gesagt dafür benötigen wir
nehmen nicht unsere diamanten und wir
benötigen auch unsere glück spitzhacke
ich glaube diese vorne drin genau glück
drei perfekt dementsprechend können wir
ganz schnell überlaufen zu unserem
amboss und ich denke dass 38 level auf
jeden fall ausreichen sollten denn diese
spitzhacke benötigen wir definitiv 35
level hat uns das jetzt gekostet
ich weiß dass es auf jeden fall noch
weitere viel bessere methoden gibt dass
diese spitzhacke nicht kaputt geht und
zwar den habe ich ja gar nicht gesehen
[Musik]
diamant spielt zac ist auf jeden fall
repariert von daher können wir uns nun
direkt um das nächste tour auf unserer
insel bzw meiner liste hier kümmern denn
ich erzählte ihr seht schon gleich voll
neben der spur
das sollte eine ganz entspannte richtig
produktive folgen werden ob ich mal
wieder geisteskrank darauf vorbereitet
auch eine menge kommentare gelesen und
jetzt ich hätte mir mehr reden
warum habe ich hier vorne immer noch ein
brötchen stehen ist aber auch egal weil
er lieben freunde denn sie können hier
jetzt endlich wieder langfahren der
tunnel wird demnächst auf jeden fall
fertig gestellt wir sehen hier unten
schon lang laufen ich jetzt sollte man
es auf jeden fall erkennt und dann geht
er da hinten irgendwann wieder hoch die
sieht allerdings auch bereits ist ich
mich an meinem leuchtturm vorbei in
richtung wüsten dort bewege denn dort
haben wir immer noch einen kandidaten
und das wollen wir auch in die
kommentare geschrieben die ich bisher
noch nicht abgeholt habe nämlich das
braune schaaf wir benötigen ja das
braune scharf auf grund der braunen
wolle die wir für unseren kopf benötigen
der dort hinten das kann man jetzt nicht
erkennen aber hinter das portal möchte
ich noch einen weiteren kopf hauen nicht
noch ein schafskopf sondern auch einen
kopf da ich die kuh ja auch leider
getötet habe von daher euch eine ganz
kurze tablets wie ich dahin fahren bevor
ich euch diese time jetzt allerdings ein
wenn
möchte ich noch ganz kurz sagen dass ich
am ende beziehungsweise nach der letzten
folge nachdem ich sie beendet haben das
habe ich auch am ende der letzten folge
noch gesagt ich habe dort meine items
sortiert ich habe ein bisschen quatsch
schon dass ich dir hier aus dem ofen
geholt und ich habe mich zur skelett
fahren bewegt und dort gewartet
sollte ich eigentlich zu beginn der
heutigen folge sagen allerdings habe ich
irgendwie vergessen von nur ganz kurz
für euch da die irgendwo ich habe nicht
getötet oder irgendwas seht ihr auch
gleich wenn ich noch mal dürfen rein
guckt allerdings fahre ich jetzt mal
schnell zum wüsten dorfen
[Musik]
so da sind wir schon wieder hier vorne
angekommen ich werde allerdings erst mal
ganz kurz auf den händler klicken
vielleicht hat der irgendwelche neuen
angebote davon benötigen wir allerdings
gar nichts von daher gehe ich jetzt mal
ganz schnell zu unserem schäfchen hier
fordere ich hoffe das es schafft hier
vorne durchzukommen commerce immer noch
nackt in die ich vielleicht ein paar
folgen dann komm
ach so du bist du dazu fett und
irgendwie durchzukommen also geht so
denn jetzt und das perfekt es klappt auf
jeden fall also wir müssen uns jetzt auf
jeden fall möchte das denn jetzt
ich muss das jetzt bis zu dem meer da
hinten muss ich jetzt so langsam da
kommen wir direkt zur nächsten teil
platz und da sind wir jetzt auch schon
wieder hier vorne an unserer kleinen los
locos insel angekommen weil er lieben
freunde das verbot werde ich einmal ganz
kurz abbauen müssen sodass das
schiffchen da vorne entspannt rausgehen
kann also wenn man hier vorne drauf
schlagen zack zack zack da steht das
haus das brötchen fange ich mal eben
ganz kurz so dass ich das hier wieder
entspannt hinsetzen kann zack zack zack
zack so einmal boot sind niveau da nicht
hinsetzen sonst wird das schiffchen
wieder eingehen also einmal kurz bitte
hier hoch kommen die ich auf 210
konzentriert perfekt und und jetzt
kannst du hier vorne wir einmal ganz
kurz mit kommen und folgen denn dann
haben wir zumindest wieder anschieben
jetzt haben wir hier zumindest schon mal
wieder ein schäfchen auf unserer insel
ich kann ihnen jetzt auch einfach mal so
ein bisschen weizen gegeben wer möchte
nicht haben den resten packe ich
dementsprechend einfach mal hier vorne
in unsere kiste rein packe genügend
essen haben meine köln schwachsinn so
das will ich machen dass man sich mitten
im zakk so das stäbchen ist hier am
start das sollte jetzt irgendwann
demnächst auf jeden fall ein bisschen
gras fressen und dann kriegen wir von
dem hoffentlich dann braunen wolle ich
hoffe jetzt einfach mal dass das
verschieben weil das wäre kompletter
reinfall wenn das jetzt im gras essen
würde und dann wäre es halt irgendwie
ein weißes schaf oder so aber da warten
jetzt einfach mal ab es gesetzlich auf
jeden fall hier unten zu unseren
schildkröten paradies hin allerdings
unter den frauen habe ich ja gerade
schon gesagt wir befinden uns wieder auf
unsere los luxusinsel ihr wisst ja das
ist der name von unserer
[Musik]
es ist auf jeden fall der name von
unserer insel hier deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht um diesen namen auch alle ehre
zu erweisen dass wir einfach mal wo habe
ich ihn denn ich habe ich weiß ein
farbstoff dass wir ein hollywood zeichen
mit dem namen los flugrost hinsetzen und
jetzt wisst ihr wahrscheinlich schon
das ist ja voll die krasse idee kommt
überhaupt von luca
ich habe mir auf jeden fall gedacht
dieses hollywood zeichen wird hier zwar
eigentlich nicht so richtig jeden passen
auf meine insel vom kompletten stil her
allerdings setzen wir auch mit der
modernen strandvilla da hinten ein
anderes zeichen und ein moderneres
zeichen den wickel uns natürlich weiter
jahr 2021 dieses projekt hier ist auch
aus dem jahr 2020 das scheißegal
denn ich wollte dass du das lukas
zeichen hier vorne quasi so ein bisschen
hinter unsere trauer insel bauen so dass
man zwar erahnen kann und sehen kann
aber ich muss erstmal ganzen nach ich
muss den ganzen beton erst mal hinsetzen
[Musik]
so freunde ich habe es jetzt fertig
gebaut und euch glaube ich auch gerade
mal kurze time labs eingeblendet denn
ich habe mich vertraut da hast dich zu
wenig ressourcen musste dann noch ein
baum fällen auf unserer trauer insel was
aber gar nicht so schlimm ist denn in
der übernächsten folge habe ich schon
ein bisschen vor geplant habe ich auf
jeden fall noch ein kleines projekt für
unsere trauer inseln allerdings ist nur
wohin derweil der lieben freunde wie du
hast doch gar nicht gesehen
okay das stimmt also ich hoffe mal voll
in ordnung also klar es ist jetzt nicht
so dass riesig geile bauprojekt wie
irgendwie der leuchtturm auf den ich
wirklich sehr stolz bin also wenn man
hier hoch läuft man einfach hinten sind
nicht diesem leuchtturm aufbauen oder
das portal schwert hier vorne was
einfach hier vornherein geht und dann
auf der anderen machen wird demnächst
wir brauchen und namensschild letztlich
sind das riesig krasse bauprojekt
allerdings seht ihr halt schon das ist
ja geil aussieht vor allem mit der
spiegelung im wasser klar dass schwebt
jetzt zum sitzen im wasser also wir
könnten eventuell demnächst nochmal ein
paar zäune irgendwie darunter setzen
dass beispielsweise hier bei dem er dann
irgendwie so ein fichtenholz zaun
runtergeht und jedoch noch im zaun dann
beim c irgendwie einen zaun bei dem l
hier blabla zumindest ins wasser rein
dass man das ein bisschen besser
erkennen kann also schreibt mir das gern
unten in die kommentare als erinnerung
dass ich das nicht vergesse ich
schreiben allerdings trotzdem noch mal
ganz kurz auf meiner to-do-liste auf da
fahren wir heute allerdings keine zeit
wenn ich bin schon wieder bei fast nach
stunde in der aufnahme und wir haben
ich hab sogar den nutzer ankommen das
was soll der geiz denn eigentlich ein
gym verabredet kann warten der scheiß
trainer
[Musik]
er kommt meine videos du bist nicht
schaffe ich lieb aber ich muss es
wirklich erzähle mal gerade fertig
machen und ihr wisst ja auch dass es in
diesem kompletten projekt darum geht
dass ich also ich also ihr seht ihr dass
das schild steht doch oder diese zone
aber ich finde wenn wir das jetzt bauen
dann sollte es auch richtig sein und ich
habe sogar hier vorne noch einen weißen
betonklotz vergessen den musste ich auch
noch kontakt wir haben die zeile
darunter gesetzt ich habe jetzt wirklich
nur einen block weit ins wasser gepackt
es ist ja aufgrund meines shaders so
dass leider die teile beziehen
das wasser so ein bisschen tiefer ist
dass sie die hier am rand auch so ein
bisschen tiefer als als die normalen
blöcke finde ich sehr sehr geil macht
allerdings dann natürlich ein bisschen
schwierig wenn ich sachen direkt auf dem
wasser bauer dann sieht es so aus als
würden die teile schweben
allerdings mag ich das ding hier mal
eben ganz kurzen und schauen wir uns den
ganzen apparat da hinten noch mal ganz
kurz an sieht auf jeden fall deutlich
besser aus sie schon einmal ganz kurz
von oben hat man es ja deutlich krasser
gesehen also das schauen wir uns auf
jeden fall auch noch kurz an und damit
haben wir dann auch schon meine lieben
freunde vier von fünf autos für die
heutige folge fertiggestellt die
deutlich besser aus also ihr seht ja
schon die zäune oder hatte er gerade
gesehen als die politik habe die sind
nicht komplett runter gegangen ins
wasser wie ich das beispielsweise hier
vorne gebaut habe bei den stelzen die
gehen ja wirklich komplett runter oder
auch bei unserer brücke hinten zu
villiger insel habe ich das ja auch so
gebaut dass es wirklich runter geht bis
ins wasser das verbraucht allerdings
wirklich eine menge ressourcen können
uns ja hier vor noch mal ganz kurz
anschauen
das geht ja auch runter bis auf den
erdboden das hier schwebt
das ist das bestimmt dass diese um die
erde
der blog hier vorne bei euch auch noch
mal eben schnell ab ich weiß wirklich
nicht warum ich die da platziert habe
allerdings ist jetzt auf jeden fall dass
wir auf einem level nur noch zwei herr
drei herzen habe ich nur noch als jetzt
ganz ganz ganz ganz fix schlafen meine
lieben freund ich da wird auf jeden fall
nicht in kontakten irgendwelchen
monstern kommen nachdem ich dann
allerdings gleich aufgewacht bin müssen
wir noch mal eben den restlichen quartz
wissen wir die restlichen glatten fläche
aus meinen öfen hier unten raus holen
ich denke mal eben kurz noch ein paar
brötchen hier rein beim bam bam bam bam
und war hier unten haben wir noch glatte
platz gewahrt bleibt drin wir haben auch
eine menge kohle hier vorne drin
und zack zack die quad blöcke lasse ich
auch direkt mal hier vorne denn die
benötigen wir für die nächste folge
da wird sich endlich mal wieder um die
um unsere strand weder gekümmert also
hier gesagt fahrzeuge rein und da wir
haben zweieinhalb stacks damit sollten
auf jeden fall ein bisschen weiter
kommen hier kommt der schadstofffreien
der weiße beton santé et cetera habe ich
ja immer hier vorne drin zusammen mit
dem kies den sand packe ich mal hier
theater sandstein ob er da habe ich hier
vorne auch drin fichtenstämme hier
einige ganz kurz meine items und wir
sehen uns gleich in der hölle wieder und
da sind wir auch schon wieder in der
unterwelt angekommen alle lieben freunde
hier hinten haben wir echt eine kranke
ändern wenn party ich weiß nicht was da
vorne abgeht ich habe zum glück noch ein
goldenes rüstungsteile von daher sollten
uns diese pickens nicht angreifen können
hier vorne immer noch die kiste da war
ich allerdings ja schon dran
ich möchte nämlich heute wieder auf so
einer sandra reiten da hinten haben wir
auf jeden fall eine hier haben wir auf
jeden fall auch noch unsere sandra die
hat hier auf uns gewartet
ich hatte die eigentlich in der letzten
folge versucht mir das portal zu nehmen
so dass sich auf der zurückgreifen kann
und sie quasi mitnehmen kann in unsere
welt die sache ist allerdings dass das
nicht richtig geklappt hatte weil sie
dann immer irgendwie vor dem portal
hingefallen war oder so allerdings
möchte ich heute mit der sandra ihr seht
schon die ist ziemlich langsam weil sie
sich gerade nicht in der lage befindet
deswegen muss ich dann mit ihr auf jeden
fall lohnen in die larven und dann
möchte ich mit ganz ganz ganz ganz weit
in eine richtung laufen
denn ich
hier bei mir im umkreis habe ich schon
alles abgesucht nach graz und den ganzen
quatsch einfach schon abgebaut deswegen
möchte ich mich ein bisschen weiter weg
bewegen und ihr wisst ja auch den quartz
benötige ich einfach um roboter händen
haben diese komischen pumpels wiederum
laufen den quad benötige ich schlichtweg
von meiner strandvilla da brauchen wir
gar nicht an dem heißen brei reden mir
fehlt einfach noch wirklich nur eine
fahrt von da ihr euch wieder eine ich
tippe 30 minuten lange time labs wie ich
hier fahrt suche
[Musik]
so harmoniert ich hab die sandra hier
vorne mal kurz eingesperrt sie hat hier
vorne auch so ein bisschen was warmes
damit ihr nicht ganz so kalt ist es ist
die längste time labs des kompletten
projekts geworden
ich weiß gar nicht mehr so lange her ist
was ich zu beginn geschätzt habe wie
lange ich unterwegs sein werde ich
glaube das waren irgendwie 30 minuten 40
minuten oder was ich auch immer gesagt
habe für euch ist das jetzt
wahrscheinlich nur ganz kurz herren
natürlich ist wieder nacht wenn ich in
meine welt reinkomme ich gehe jetzt mal
direkt schlafen damit ihr nicht noch
mehr monster kommen und zweitens vorteil
von ländern werden rum und plot uns
irgendwelche blöcke und dann werde ich
euch mal zeigen was ich alles im
inventar habe also erstmal schnell hier
vorne rein sagt hier vorne zu machen
hier habe ich jetzt ich hab ich denn da
nicht lebend erzählt okay ich gehe mal
ganz schnell eben penan ich habe auch
irgendwann in der time jetzt habe ich
die fackeln hier auf meinen zweiten slot
genommen nicht mein schwert so dass ihr
ein bisschen es in monster
[Musik]
ich sehe auch keine wieso kann ich dir
nicht schlafen schuld zu jetzt plötzlich
schlafen kann ich es nicht
ist aber auch egal meine lieben freunde
denn
es ist es ist einfach nur der absolute
wahnsinn
ich hab mal wie schön das hinaus was
lukas ich habe täglich im netz
diese ganzen sachen abgebaut
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ein halb sechs
[Musik]
es ist wirklich unglaublich ich hab
nicht mal so viele höfe um den ganzen
quartier einzupacken
das wird ich will es eigentlich nicht
sagen aber ich denke dass das zu 100
prozent ausreichen wird um unsere
strandhaus villa fertig zu bauen meine
lieben freunde ich habe zudem auch noch
mich eigentlich gar nicht zu beginn
darauf konzentriert gold abzubauen
dann jedoch trotzdem zwischendurch
gedacht hey komm so ein bisschen davon
kann ich ja mit nehmer so habe ich auf
die eine menge goldklumpen mitgenommen
ich werde die items jetzt nochmal ganz
fix sortieren meine lieben freunde da
lasse ich euch hier jetzt auch noch eben
daran teilhaben mein gott das war jetzt
schon so eine lange folge hier mit der
ganzen mit den ganzen timeless und so
weiter und sofort könnt ihr auch dass
sie kurz auf euch mit mir zusammen
anschauen also dass hier sind die ganzen
goldbarren die ich geholt habe fast ein
spac dann halt mehr oder weniger zack
hier vorne noch den aufteilen denen
aufteilen zack zack zack und den hier
vorne und nochmal beim und bahn
dann haben wir hier auf jeden fall eine
menge wirklich eine riesige menge gold
die werde ich jetzt auch direkt zu gold
blöcken verarbeiten sodass wir ein
bisschen mehr platz in unserer kiste
haben die gold blöcke hier rein die
goldbarren hier rein und die quartz
blöcke die ich ja auch noch hier vorne
drin habe das sind wirklich so unfassbar
viele die lasse ich jetzt einfach im
inventar in meine lieben freunde an der
stelle beendet jetzt auch heute endlich
das video in der nächsten episode
übermorgen müssen auf jeden fall
einsteigen werden einschalten wir werden
nämlich die zweite etage meiner
strandhaus villa fertig bauen
ich freue mich extrem darauf vielleicht
haben wir sogar die komplette villa
fertig zu bauen das ist ein großes
projekt und daher daumendrücken meine
lieben freunde lasst die daumen hoch und
video da wenn's euch gefallen hat
abonniert man den kanal und klickt auf
die glocke um das neue video übermorgen
nicht zu verpassen
ich habe euch lieb und ich muss jetzt
direkt schlafen gehen
[Musik]